I think the Stars rub the entire film  with both the clothes the settings the  cars the music I think it's an error  that people just love to have a romantic  you are too kind of indulge we must give  them an appropriate well coming I've got  a chance to wear some really cool  tailored suits  the costumes were all wonderful do you  want to check it I love with her yes the  most i know three layers of eyelashes so  sorry I can't stay to finish you off  myself a little Vespa that we wrote yeah  I love that little hair know how I  survived pity it's amazing then all the  great classic cars it felt like you were  back there I mean you really feel like  you're there in the 60s which would have  been fun thing do these belong to you or  to me